- Daniel I wanted to start by asking you
about the choice to executive produce
this film because I am just a big fan of
any actor out there who wants to help
get the kinds of films they want made
made themselves so what made you make
that choice on this one I believed in
there from the very beginning we're not
ready I said what can I do what can I do
to help how can I do to help funding all
that stuff goes in like I'm kind of do
do what do what needs to be done and
have those conversations and even just
like I mean there's another thing as
well as is a history of like American
films that we've black leads not
performing internationally and it's just
a very prejudiced ideology Jose Annan
and it's just like being not from
America I wanna help that Jose Annan and
try and change that narrative so and
also just I'll just contribute as much
as I can to the script and do what needs
to be done something you continue doing
Jody you're not new to the industry by
any means but the first lead role in a
major feature film did there was there
nerves that kind of came with that and
what was the source of comfort that
wound up putting you at ease I don't
think I ever felt comfortable during the
process like oh it's fine I got this you
know I mean the whole time it was
something that I fully was like this is
number one unlike anything I've ever
done before and when you get into it and
you actually see like actually huh I
mean it's challenging you know it was so
it never stopped being challenging but
it was just something what I released
myself to was just the eagerness to wrap
my arms around it you know and not stay
in the conversation about how I mean you
know obviously there's you're never
gonna not be like [ __ ] yourself oh
my god but then you just have to switch
gears and go into and and and it was
also made very it was very much easy for
me to do that by
whoo-hoo just constantly just sort of
like take me under his wing and look
after me and check in with me and and
and even you don't give me feedback and
and just like must encourage me and it
was it was amazing you know for that
that really that really pushed me
through I mean Daniel I'm a big believer
in the fact that there are no silly
questions but I know when you're first
starting out and like you're at the top
of the Call Sheet like that you might
have questions about the process that
maybe you're afraid to ask and even for
you when you were first starting out is
there anything that you wish someone
kind of answered for you maybe something
you were nervous to ask about at the
very beginning sex scenes what's going
on Tony's a sit down have a conversation
about things cuz I know how I have sex
[Laughter]
and then and then marks it's like the
technical you do not realize how
technicals moviemaking is Johnson and so
like I wish like something like even
understand and I think a lot of people
just understanding what every department
does and I'm just very curious press so
I'll go to I don't know a graphic of
what you do like what you do in like
it's insane but it's um it's how you
know understand under your the acting
Department and you need to kind of
figure out how you slot into this whole
machine and no one kind of tells you
what this isn't that isn't that isn't it
yeah hitting marks is ever that cuz
skillset in itself just and it's so
important if you if it's our focus it
it's felt on screen and you can waste
time so it's um yeah anything else you
want to add I mean I just thought that
is definitely like marks Cameron's all
the technical aspects of it that and
especially if I mean I didn't go to
drama school I had you know I walked
into the whole thing not very green and
just kind of like figuring it out
unfortunately I got to kind of learn how
to do all the stuff on television show
where I didn't have much to do other
than learn how to do it so that was
really good yeah but yeah I mean you
wish that somebody's gonna sit you down
and it's like understand this cuz when
you get into it and then everybody else
knows what they're doing and you were
like I don't know I'm doing it wasn't
all fun know what she's doing I wanted
to ask you could we play a game on
collateral would you rather all the time
and one question pertains to your role
so well would you rather have to run
throughout an entire scene or eat
throughout an entire scene because you
eat so much in this movie that it
stressed me out
you son of a mom last night she told me
not to say any anecdotes about her but
ever again but I'm gonna say it she said
you need to stop eating and acting but
what would I do
Robert run or eat for Tennessee eat eat
because you run out of steam when you
run and then they'll blatantly use that
take and you just look like a star
though I'm just afraid to overeat and
then get sick so I always go for the
running I just
[Laughter]